die opferbilanz im us staat new york man
auch in new york city sind weiter im
steigen begriffen jetzt hat andrew cuomo
der gouverneur neue schockierende zahlen
bekannt gegeben im gesamten staat sind
779 tote zu beklagen gewesen in einem
zeitraum von 24 stunden das ist leider
ein neuer rekordwert new york tut sich
unterdessen schwert mit den vielen toten
umzugehen jetzt wurde auf einem
parkplatz am rendl silent ein quasi park
von sattelschleppern er errichtet
eingerichtet dort bauen arbeiter diese
anhänger der sattelschlepper um zu
mobilen leichenhallen hier werden
holzgestelle eingebaut in die dann die
toten übereinander gelegt werden können
bis zu 50 leichen sollen in einen dieser
anhänger passen 50 dieser
sattelschlepper sind bereits dort auf
diesem parkplatz das wäre also eine
kapazität von 2.500 toten eigentlich
fast so viel wie die gesamte opferbilanz
am elfter september bei den
terroranschlägen alleine das
verdeutlicht wie kritisch die lage nach
wie vor ist in new york der gouverneur
allerdings bemüht sich mit
durchhalteparolen die bevölkerung doch
ein wenig aufzubauen er sagte die zahl
der einlieferungen in die spitäler ist
gesunden das wäre ein positives zeichen
möglicherweise sogar ein silberstreif am
horizont como warnte aber auch dass es
ein langer weg zurück sein werde
bis zu einer neuen normalität er sagte
auch dass das frühere alte normal
vielleicht gar nicht mehr existieren
wird in der zukunft ein weiterer
rückschlag für den new yorker ist die
tatsache dass jetzt die broadway-theater
weiter geschlossen bleiben sogar bis zum
siebten juni der längst das längste
zusperren der psychiater in der
geschichte des broadway nicht viel
besser ziel ist die lage im rest der usa
es hat einen neuen rekord gegeben in
ganz amerika 1900 personen sind an einem
einzigen tag gestorben
das ist neuerlich ein weltrekord die
lage in den usa bleibt also extrem
angespannt und natürlich am schlimmsten
ist die situation in new york dem ground
zero dem hotspot der amerikanischen
carola virus pandemie